l'état des vitrines des deux bijouterie
braquée l'une et l'autre à quelques
minutes d'intervalle en dit long sur la
violence du choc
il était 4 heures du matin ce couple
habite juste au dessus de l'un des
magasins et a été réveillé par le fracas
de la voiture bélier
on a cru que c'est un incendie en
descendant on est venu jusqu'à l'ain et
c'est là qu'on a vu la voiture on a cru
que c'était un accident puis c'est après
qu'on a vu la bijouterie cas c'est tout
c'est là qu'on a compris à qui a donc
une forte odeur d'essence
et puis on sait qu'ils avaient mis le
feu parce que la fumée qui sortait de
partout
de chaque côté d'eux des bouches
d'aération nous penser que c'est un
incendie le magasin disposait d'un
système de fumigènes anti-cambriolage
son propriétaire avait déjà subi un
braquage à main armée il y a quelques
années
aujourd'hui s'il est encore difficile
d'évaluer le butin le préjudice lié à
l'attaqué elle même est considérable au
premier abord quand on entre toutes les
vitres sont explosés les vitrines on se
sont déplacés ça a été arraché le
plafond également vous voyez l'état de
notre rideau métallique en extérieur
voilà dans un contexte déjà très
particulier cette année avec cette
semaine de fermeture
c'est lourd et c'est pas évident car
voilà cette girouette séduire à deux
mois de noël de moi ni de noël la police
scientifique est actuellement sur place
tentant de relever un maximum d'un 10
d'après les images des caméras de
surveillance visionné par le
propriétaire
on distingue deux individus les témoins
disent également avoir vu une seconde
voiture dans laquelle il se serait enfui
laissant la 1re encastré dans la vitrine